okay I think it's just funny how much
you hated eggs
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome you believe your circle her
uh hi
ah this is amazing frog we are the
amazing progress uh
I'm top right I'm the big one
yeah uh I'm just dragging myself we
don't know what this games Oh arcades
what the heck oh no oh no I don't want
this okay that's that's not what we're
looking no hey buddy do we saw aah oh
God
we start you know this good haha Bob
we're playing together
oh wait now you're just playing this
whole other game even oh it's get whoa
oh whoa
finally we found the way to go I think
okay so we've never played the amazing
frog before none of us not oh no laughs
I don't have any idea what you're
supposed to be why you're supposed to do
it Oh God
okay [ __ ] is this oh stop wait oh oh
okay my why is this oh it's so laggy oh
no oh no this is gonna stay okay I'm
gonna can go but I got this thing what
is this too
oh there's a cannon whoa
okay what would you go oh baby what's up
what's up blue [ __ ] oh my god oh
jeez some floppy frogs we got here is
your an objective to this room this goat
simulator with ROG's and multiplayer I
think I think you ha ha ha you got your
bag you go check it out
ah can we get in cars I don't think so I
blew up a car when I hit it with the
cannon
I'm in the back yeah how did you in the
car you get back to the cannon walk lazy
sack of crap why do you want to come
ride my car yeah I'm gonna shoot my way
right there it's not at NVC just
endlessly running into what my present
this option [ __ ] bail on this thing
you can be hard to watch
it's hardly playing is it no I'm gonna
watch this
wait well look at this guy Oh God my
hands [ __ ] emitter go to spam jump you
can walk around like this stuff in the
car mom oh I can set you up like I'll
help you up friend a big oh dear friend
I think Oh where why - look who's gone
oh oh
ha how'd you do that
am i dad did I kill you you killed me oh
lady then Oh back are we supposed to
kill each other oh my god you've won
whoa what happened to be there look now
I'm mounting oh oh never mind
I got a yeah good good all right now
look it Dom cross cross banking you all
over the place
give it up looks [ __ ] deafening Oh
why are you shaped like a huge dick big
brother
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey easy
lil whoa come here wait I want to ride
the tram pin with Mark set us on the
trampoline uh
game is great this game ah see ya what
all right you know what mark you oh all
right you can exist
all right thank you in comment and got
it oh [ __ ] oh boy I'm going for a
yourself on a pickle bird there's a
little boy on the ground who's this it's
a ah wait wait
micro what is it what hey a little piece
of bone well he's over here now Hey oh
come here
wha wha just crank him off a criminal
did it crowd yeah yeah oh [ __ ] dude ah
[ __ ] crown [ __ ] crown Oh mere
[ __ ] come here [ __ ] you never very
kitchen mister take this crown hide it
hey hey hide it Oh
ah God you [ __ ] ah never catch me now
oh I think okay
come here [ __ ] Oh our ship part that I
crown [ __ ] that my [ __ ] walked
around got my [ __ ] crying over there
[ __ ] I can't don't go the right way
there we go you know I [ __ ] around
over there zelich oh oh oh yes oh yeah
okay yes all right Matt Hummer I got you
[ __ ]
get mark after the beer [ __ ] Oh
God our bodies were tangled in the
mysterious dance of love what if I do
this yeah see ya oh I mean my
impenetrable king car now [ __ ]
driving around okay take me to church it
won't go bad it doesn't drive well we
say the car hey well let's pretend to
drive okay why don't you start the car
mark says Jack septic
alright Wow let's get the [ __ ] out of
this [ __ ] let's go somewhere else doc
okay Oh frogs milk frog milk coffee
alright there's stuff I I'm better at
least say hello hello oh here we go nope
I'm just gonna if I could poop
I got my crown back [ __ ] it no please
it's up it's if I can get my own whoa
I'm gonna get a rock star hot coffee I
don't know four points to get this you
just got the Frog milk capital F at
earning reports for doing immediately
just start to say soon get ketchup on
bloom in great coffee hey I'm driving it
are you I'm grabbing it how'd you learn
to drive okay so I come coming I
currently have the objective to destroy
oh wait wait the whole 3.0 know if I
stand up I get out hang up whoa yeah
alright would you like to go let's go no
we use the rail let's try to get one
more person oh all right I got oh let me
back in all right let's party I'm
farting for some reason there I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming in there we go
first yeah let's go let's go hit that
sick random yeah by the the trampoline
yeah okay yeah oh hey well I was
exciting that's almost not hilarious at
all I want
I'm in the back [ __ ] that
hey how's he kill kid I'm in my second
now city up a whole dark blue truck okay
please get the car ha ha ha ha ha there
we go uh I'm not gonna fall yell more
drives wait
oh no is it hang on sec wait oh oh
buddy these are left-hand Drive
oh [ __ ] this is the driver's seat
we're just idiots IV just write and
drive yeah it's the opposite whoa whoa
man everyone was just calling us [ __ ]
idiots are a long time so are we gonna
keep in the moment where I said we
should [ __ ] bail [ __ ] bail on this
game yes we shouldn't wait just rip a
little wall kinda okay do it do it
ba ba ba whoa all-you-can-eat break a is
ebrake oh hell yeah you can go first
person in the car with left bumper nice
this doesn't help
yeah it doesn't really help at all does
it weird Jesus Christ
yeah am i seeso robber here perfect
currently approaching quick are you my
modern art
all right around the corner from you Bob
I thought so
all right so Jim the pic ah all right
I found the fig where's this thing goes
in your monitor heart Bob Bob oh this
new customer cus my guiltily girl the
big audio he's okay okay he's okay
alright have to grab the big gonna test
to grab the picture Justin Brown leave
that thing there oh my god we're trying
a big [ __ ] you give me the pillow
Aisling this big oh I have no control
over this booty yeah oh god I'm gonna
help I'm gonna help okay
please help me control the picu me that
crap [ __ ] oh oh alright
riding pic could you gain control over
the pic right now I can semi control the
pic but it's very slight II whoa area
what held it okay I am currently
controlling a pickle can I get on with
you try ah sorry sorry okay you can't
wait wait wait wait I believe it I
thought you come towards us I'm
attempting to ramp the pig oh I like
this look for this is going ha ha ha his
back legs are freaking the [ __ ] ha ha
ha come on there mr. pig oh no no no in
the opposite way of that that phrase
what are you doing is a good place to
park which do there big man oh you got
out of there okay yeah oh oh yes wow
that's a good place apart
alright well okay I think we've only
explored this game dude Bob back up
really flowing the car and we're aiming
to be as fast as you can I
circles happened guys here here so that
was the amazing truck we ability we have
no idea what we're doing or why we did
it but uh we have no idea leave it even
if this is a video that didn't give
anyone a migraine anyway thank everybody
somebody watching giggling at this booth
Shanga yeah yeah so uh let us know what
you thought down the cops below oh oh
yeah and everybody for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next is it
exactly that's the chase I'm [ __ ] out
of here